mr. yang your signature policy is to
give every adult in the United States
$1,000 a month no questions asked that's
right I think that's like three point
two trillion dollars a year how would
you do that sorry how would you do that
oh so it's difficult to do if you have
companies like Amazon trillion-dollar
tech companies paying literally zero in
taxes while they're closing 30% of our
stores now we need to put the American
people in position to benefit from all
these innovations and other parts of the
economy and if we had a value-added tax
even half the European level it would
generate over 800 billion in new revenue
which combined with the money in our
hands it would be the trickle up economy
from our people families and communities
up we would spend the money and would
circulate through our regional economies
and neighborhoods creating millions of
jobs making our families stronger and
healthier we'd save money on things like
incarceration homelessness services
emergency room health care and just the
value gains from having a stronger
healthier mentally healthier population
would increase GDP by seven hundred
billion dollars this is the move that we
have to make particularly as technology
is now automating away millions of
American jobs it's why Donald Trump is
our president today that we automated
away four million manufacturing jobs in
Michigan Ohio and Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin and we're about to do the same
thing to millions of retail jobs call
center jobs fast food jobs truck driving
jobs are selling on through the economy
Jerry if I get you understand a little
bit better so you saying $1,000 a month
for everyone over 18 but a value-added
tax so you can spend that thousand
dollars on value-added tax
well the value-added tax would end up
you'd still be increasing the buying
power of the bottom 94 percent of
Americans you have to spend a lot of
money for a mild value-added tax to eat
up twelve thousand dollars a year per
individual so for the average family
with two or three adults would be 24 to
36 thousand dollars a year